if you're not ready to have a kid and
you're 30 and you have a partner whether
you're single or whether you have a
partner
you need to start thinking about
freezing whether it's an egg or an
embryo for your future
so i my rule is 30. other i've seen
other doctors talk about 35 i have
people that come in at 35 and their
fertility is already down the drain
welcome to episode 89 of the michaela
peterson podcast
in this episode i'm joined by dr shaheen
gadir
dr gadir is a renowned specialist in
infertility
and reproductive endocrinology we
discussed the high rates of infertility
and what to do about it if you're having
trouble conceiving
in vitro fertilization the actual
process of freezing eggs
which isn't as scary as i thought what
healthy eggs sperm and embryos look like
the changes in the fertility rate and
more if you're a late 20s to mid 30s
individual and you haven't had kids
and you don't want to rule out that
possibility i think this is information
everyone should know i find people are
pretty casual about their reproductive
life
and sometimes they hit late 30s and are
like oh age matters
yes it does and there are things you can
do to prevent
having no children if you really don't
want to have kids young or haven't
figured out your life yet
i certainly haven't if you like this
kind of information
please hit subscribe this episode is
brought to you by true local
they're where i used to get 80 of my
meat until i left canada at least until
it opens up properly
true local partners with local farmers
and butchers in your area to source
really high quality meat they're very
picky about quality
if you're worried about fertility or you
want to get healthier adding more meat
into your diet is the easiest and
yummiest thing you can do
true local cells 100 grass-fed and
grass-finished beef
pasture-raised or rwa chicken raised
without antibiotics
lamb bison liver and more they have over
100 different cuts of meat that you
might not be able to find at your local
grocery store
and some vegetables now their lamb is
amazing
you can go to truelocal.ca that's tru
local.ca or trulocalusa.com
and then build your own personalized box
it shows up at your door flash
frozen and with code mp you get free
stakes in your order
tru local.ca or trulocalusa.com
depending on where you're from
code mp thank you dr gadir for this
episode it's a short one but it's chock
full of valuable information
remember to hit subscribe if you learned
something or enjoy it
dr shaheen gadir welcome to my podcast
thank you so much for having me
so can we start off by you giving a
brief background about
uh who you are and what it is you do
absolutely so my name is shaheen gadir
i'm a reproductive endocrinology and
infertility specialist
at southern california reproductive
center and what that means is i'm a
fertility specialist i help people
achieve their goals of growing their
families
preserving their fertility for the
future and doing every single thing that
they need to
to have that perfect family that they
always dreamed about
okay i'm gonna throw a whole bunch of
questions at you
starting with i'm ready okay okay great
um
is infertility usually caused by men or
women
um we used to always think that it's
more of a female problem of course
and it's not it is probably equally
caused by male and female the most
recent studies have shown that about 40
percent is caused by males about 40
percent by females
and there's another like 20 that we have
absolutely no idea
what is causing and it's called
unexplained infertility
okay good to know so do you deal with
women's infertility and
men's infertility so i'm a board
certified ob gyn
um and as a result of being an ob gyn
then i did a fellowship program for
three years
uh which was done at cedars-sinai and
ucla medical centers
it specializes in female however even if
the problem is with the male
a lot of the treatment has to go through
the females so for example if a male has
no sperm
and we have to have one of our urology
colleagues go into the testicle and like
retrieve a little bit of sperm
the female still has to go into ivf and
we have to still retrieve those eggs so
we can take that sperm and put it back
into her eggs
so that they they basically both become
my patient both husband
and wife and male and female but at the
same time i also have
a lot of gay couples two men involved
and they're all my patients because i
have to find them egg donors
and surrogates and everything involved
with trying to get a pregnancy moving
forward
okay okay so what is can you tell me
what
ivf is and how it's done
yeah absolutely so ivf stands for in
vitro
fertilization the word in vitro means
outside of the human body
and in vivo is inside so this is
fertilization of the egg and the sperm
outside of the female body
so it's done in a laboratory environment
in an incubator in petri dishes
so that is what in vitro is basically
you're making an embryo
in a laboratory environment
okay and how are the eggs retrieved
so there's a process of about 10 to 12
days of injections that we teach a
female to give themselves in their
belly if they can't do it we bring them
into the office and we do them here
with that being said once the eggs begin
to grow
usually takes about 10 to 12 days and
then the eggs are retrieved in our
surgery center
it's right here on our floor it's our
anesthesiologist
starts an iv and in the iv they push a
little bit of sedative medicine that
makes someone fall asleep
you're totally breathing on your own
it's a deep sleep
lasts about three to five minutes
there's an ultrasound placed vaginally
at the tip of the ultrasound there's a
special needle that helps us
retrieve um the eggs that have grown
that month and then you wake up and it's
pretty much done you don't know that it
happened and you don't feel anything
if you had a lot of eggs you may be a
little crampy afterwards
but usually within a day or two most
people are feeling back to normal
okay and so these injections that women
are taught to give themselves is that
a hormone to increase egg production
it's not a hormone it's a stimulant of
the pituitary gland in the brain
that then signals the ovaries and the
ovary then makes its own hormone which
is called estrogen
and estrogen is the fuel for the eggs to
grow normally we get a little bit of
that happening with the injections we
get a bunch of that happening
so instead of getting one egg egg that
you release every month
we can potentially get five 10 15 25 30
eggs out of someone depending on their
egg reserve and their age
okay and so this is just a month-long
process you don't have to
take the like pituitary stimulating
hormone it's usually
for months for this to happen yeah the
pituitary stimulants
usually last for about 10 to 12 days for
most people we usually put them on a
birth control for a week or two before
this stops
this process starts in order to stop
their natural ovulation
so in term it's about a one month
process
the first two weeks i just tell people
you're gonna be taking you're going to
do one blood test and an ultrasound and
if everything looks good you're going to
take one birth control pill
a day for about average a week or two
and then you go into the week or two of
injections and then you're done with it
so it rarely is longer than a one month
process and then
the embryos are created we let the
embryos grow for one week in our
incubators
at the end of that week we're also
eligible and able to do
a little tiny biopsy on all of the nice
embryos that grew nicely
and then we can get genetic testing
results usually back in the week or two
telling us
from the embryos that grew nicely from
the ones that got a little biopsy
and frozen which ones are able to be
genetically normal and then
transferred back into the woman in the
following month or in the future
how often is that successful once
they're transferred back
so once they're genetically normal and
healthy and frozen
our success rate in the practice is 76
to 84
for a genetically tested normal embryo
which is probably
one of the highest in the world wow
okay so what's the difference between
that process and
just say you're considering freezing
eggs
so no embryo um what's the difference
between trying to harvest eggs yeah
well let me just explain for those
people that don't know what the
difference between an egg and an embryo
is
so the embryo if i didn't make it clear
enough is basically the sperm and egg
together
fertilizing and then growing for a week
outside of the body
the egg is just the egg as it comes out
of the female body
we check to see which eggs are mature
they are frozen
and all the immature ones are then
discarded so you're unable to
let the embryo grow you're unable to
let the embryo have genetic testing so
it's just a simple egg
and we know which ones are mature until
you come back with the use of sperm
you can't make it into an embryo you
can't let it grow for a week and you
won't know which ones are genetically
normal
and lead to a new a normal embryo that
potentially has a very high chance of
around 80
um going to a live birth
okay so for for harvesting eggs is it
the same kind of
birth control and then harvesting same
money same
exact process everything happens outside
the egg is out of the body so for the
female
it's the same exact process a little bit
of birth control to stop your ovulation
and then about 10 days 12 days of the
injections until we get the egg
but then once you're outside of the body
is when the differentiation happens we
either freeze them on that day
or we start to create with the sperm the
embryo and then watch it grow for a week
and wait for genetic testing results
okay um so
in a like a different type of question
how has
uh men's fertility and women's fertility
changed over the last
you know number of decades or say 50
years i've heard it's gone down
it has gone down but for lots of
different reasons um
one of the most important reasons is if
we think about our parents and our
grandparents and the age that they were
starting their families it's very
different than
what we're doing right now in the world
there are many career-driven women out
there
that are not ready to have a child in
their early 20s and want to grow their
careers
and do everything they want to do until
they're ready many of our parents and
grandparents were having
their kids before they're even 20 years
of age or in their early 20s or in their
20s
so that's the number one aspect that
affects for
female fertility is the decline that
comes
naturally with an aging female and as
we know that you know menopause is
around the age of 50. so people begin to
have a significant decline after 40.
women have a general decline of their
fertility starting at like 26 27 28
years of age
so that's why the trend of trying to
freeze your eggs
closer to the age of 30 is growing
rapidly and for men it's a little bit
more stable even though there's sperm
production
throughout your life until the day you
pass after the age of 40 there's been a
lot of
issues that have you know caused decline
in male fertility and also the
well-being of embryos
genetic abnormalities causes like that
i also think that the environmental
factors can't be ignored at all
i think it's really important to be
aware like there's so many environmental
stimulants around us that are
not healthy for men for women simple
things from
preservatives and all those ingredients
and a food that we don't even know what
they are and going into our body
to simple other things that are just
alcohol
you know in many parts of the world
marijuana use is legal
however it's still bad for fertility um
it affects fertility in a negative way
and i think it's just important to be
aware of your environments as well and
those things cause
effects on male and female fertility all
the time
okay that was going to be one of my
questions is what are the worst things
for fertility and you said
alcohol drugs preservatives unknown
chemicals i have to say
drinking alcohol in a responsible way
like you go to dinner and you have a
glass of wine or two here and there
i think there's absolutely nothing wrong
with that personally um
but i think you know the use of smoking
and
excessive alcohol or you know
recreational drugs definitely can help
in a negative way
but there's other other things as well
you know the use of like for men for
example like the use of super tight
underwear and super tight pants and
steam rooms and jacuzzis and saunas and
excessive spinning and cycling all these
things that we don't even think about
or putting a laptop on your lap that
generates a lot of heat from the bottom
you know those things could be negative
over time and it's things that we have
to all be aware of
okay yes that's a little bit scary
it is do you so how
how expensive is this treatment for
let's say storing eggs or
let's let's start with storing eggs you
know it varies
um the so many insurance policies
and a lot of like the tech companies or
some of the more advanced employers
like disney and netflix and snapchat
and you know apple you know they cover a
lot of this for patients i mean like
wow many of my patients have like 75 000
coverage
but many people still do not and many
insurance
carriers still do not cover it we have
specials that go as low as
6 400 and if not i think that the
regular egg freezing cost is around 8
000 then there's the medications and the
medications
can vary you know they're very expensive
there's major monopoly on the
medications from the companies the
pharmaceutical companies that make them
there's not 50 different companies that
make them there's like three
so they're expensive and they can be a
few thousand dollars just for the
medications alone
the longer you wait the older you become
your body's gonna require
more medicine in order to make less eggs
so that's why
the younger you do this the healthier
you do this when you have more eggs
the better chances are that you're going
to make a lot of eggs with the use of as
little medicine as possible
okay so is this something like is this
something you recommend for your friends
you know that are in their twenties if
just injured everyone is something yeah
any woman who has a i tell them even if
you have a one percent chance
or the tiniest chance that you may want
to have a future family
to be really honest there's a lot of
women that think they want to have no
families but like
37 38 39 40 comes around there's
something that i have noticed
change in the female body there is
something
about changes that happen with a woman
that maybe their thoughts of parenthood
change and they desire to have kids when
it may be too late
so i would recommend it as an insurance
policy for one of the most
important biggest aspects of your life
which is having a beautiful family and
having the kids that you want to have
without major struggles
it's an investment but we make
investments in our future all the time
we make investments in our home we make
investments for car insurance so we
in case we get in an accident and this
isn't a major investment that we need to
make in ourselves
i thought that freezing eggs was more
expensive to tell you the truth
is the in vitro fertilization process
more
it is more because at that point once we
get the egg out of the body
we have to go through all the sperm we
have to pick the best sperm
we inject the sperm into the egg which
is called intracytoplasmic sperm
injection
or also known as icsi or ixe
then we have to incubate and let the
embryo grow for a week
we have special incubators that take
thousands of pictures a day
and the embryo never has to be even
removed from the incubator you know that
machine alone costs hundreds of
thousands of dollars
um it's called an embryo scope so if you
choose to use that it'll add additional
cost but it's been proven to give better
embryo results
once the embryos grow for a week you
know that biopsy process which is
very technically difficult and
cumbersome
is a process that you know there's a
charge for once the embryos are biopsied
they have to be frozen that's another
process that is involved
and then the genetic testing that's done
adds up as well
and then the embryo has to be frozen and
so do eggs
and there's an annual storage fee so it
begins to add up significantly
but with the embryo you know a lot more
on the other side
um and right then and there at the end
of the two weeks three week process you
know exactly what you have
waiting for you to be used in the future
and by knowing all of that
information there's more involved in the
lab and there's more cost involved too
okay and you said when when people have
these embryos there's a 70 to 80
chance of them taking once does that
have anything to do with how old
though female is when she decides to
have this treatment done
yeah so when you're like 44 years old
and doing this
many people don't even have one good egg
left some people may have one or two
good
eggs left so you're not going to get
that much you're going to get maybe a
few and that's why we encourage people
when they're 30 years old and you're
able to make like you know 20 30 eggs
and get like you know
five to ten genetically normal embryos
out of it or just have healthy eggs
sitting there for you for the future
it's so much smarter to do it at a
younger age
and keep them there for the future
okay so say you get it done at 30 and
then you want to have a kid and you're
45
and you haven't gone through menopause
does the age when you use your eggs
um like does it is there less of a
chance of it working if you're older
when you use young eggs
um no but yes as well so
if you come in at 45 and by then you're
like obese
diabetic hypertensive have a lot of
medical issues
it's a complication and it's going to be
a disastrous pregnancy for you
because anyone over the age of 35 is at
higher risk for advanced maternal age
being pregnant
if you're 45 and an excellent health
which many of my patients are
all of the well-being of the
implantation and the rate of
implantation and your success
all of that is going to have to do with
the age that you made the embryo
so as long as the embryo is genetically
normal and the younger you are you make
more you have more options to use in the
future
okay that's crazy that you're able to do
that that's amazing yeah
um okay so what i had a couple i think
and by the way sorry just add something
out there
you're gonna love this we've had a
patient of ours who came back and used
her embryo
15 years later and had a beautiful baby
her own biological child
that's insane it is wow
that's incredible yeah that's incredible
okay um i i posted some questions on
instagram and i got asked from a couple
of people who had either endometriosis
or pcos so um
how they could either get healthier or
what how they could increase the
likelihood that they could have a kid
so that's great i think for both of
those
topics endometriosis is the process
where
the lining of the uterus actually grows
outside of the uterus
so it grows on the fallopian tube it can
grow on the ovary it can grow anywhere
in the pelvic cavity
and it's an extremely painful process
because every month when your
uterine lining gets thick and engorged
right when you begin to have your period
it gets thick and engorged inside of
your body as well so it's really painful
but when it happens it also if it
happens on the ovary
the chemicals involved with
endometriosis affect the egg
and egg quality goes down as well it's
the same exact thing with polycystic
ovary syndrome or pcos
which is usually based with problems
with your insulin receptors
and there's a higher amount excessive
amount of
uh male hormones like testosterone
floating around your body
they also have a negative effect on your
egg quality as well
so both of those both of those issues
both endometriosis and pcos it is
probably
smarter to tuck away a bunch of eggs
earlier on in your life
knowing that you have those issues and
hopefully being able to use them in a
healthier way
and with ivf in the laboratory we have
so much more control
on trying to make a healthy genetically
normal beautiful embryo for you
than internally in your office and
you're inside your body sorry doing it
all yourself
okay so you said pcos has something to
do with your
your uh response to insulin or insulin
receptors is there any way that that's
going to work
uh yeah a lot of pcos patients are
overweight so the first thing i would
recommend to them
is try to lose as much weight as
possible even a 10 decline in their
weight
has been proven to improve their pcos
and egg quality
so that's one of the first things there
are other medications such as like
metformin also called glucophage
which are insulin sensitivity
medications so they're usually given to
patients with borderline early stage
diabetes
to make their insulin receptors work
better so for that reason we tell them
that it's a great idea
to do that early on um because it can
help
and it could be a long-term kind of
effect of helping egg quality
um sometimes you know birth control
pills bring down those male hormones as
well
but it really it depends on if someone's
trying to actively be pregnant with pcos
or just trying to
make the symptoms of pcos better and
some of the the symptoms are awful
like male pattern baldness and
no body hair growth that happens that
are unwanted areas for women
yeah that's no fun
no okay let's see what else do i have is
there any
there's no way that this is this i'm
gonna ask anyway though
is there any way to why is it that so
many people who do
ivf that i've heard of have end up
having twins or something
um so many clinics don't have the most
amazing success rates
and in the past we had many patients
that were like just
very desperate to be pregnant so the
clinic would put more embryos in
you know sometimes two three and
horrible cases even more than that
um our clinic has a rule we never put
more than two embryos in but we put two
embryos in for people that are very
interested in trying to have twins
the majority of our patients over 90
only put one embryo back in
so i think the better clinics around the
world are putting one embryo in at a
time
some countries even have rules you can
only put one in at a time
so i think it's a lot of patient choice
at this time of putting two embryos in
wow okay i didn't know you were able to
do this
huh that's amazing again okay
so when's the ideal time to start
looking into your fertility in your
opinion
what's the ideal age i think if you've
hit 30 and you haven't thought about it
you need to address it
so any woman whether in there in a and
the other thing is that there's a lot of
women that get married and have a
partner and then they just ignore things
as if like if you're not ready to have a
kid
and you're 30 and you have a partner
whether you're single or whether you
have a partner
you need to start thinking about
freezing whether it's an egg or an
embryo for your future
so i my rule is 30. other i've seen
other doctors talk about 35 i have
people that come in at 35 and their
fertility is already down the drain
how do you check how fertile somebody is
uh there's a couple
there's a few different tests a simple
one that we do
is a blood test and it's called the amh
blood test
amh is a hormone that comes from the
eggs the higher the level of amh
on a blood test the more eggs you have
doing an ultrasound and looking at the
ovary to see how many tiny little
bubbles there are
those are called antral follicles that
actually gives you a higher
visibility of the well-being of your
ovary
wow okay and then what about i've heard
and i guess you
aren't the person necessarily to ask
about this but i've heard about freezing
sperm
i've heard that there's a clinic
somewhere that does that so
so we actually do that in our we do that
in our own practice too okay so our lab
also freezes firm for any man who's
interested about preserving their
fertility
there's a lot of sperm banks around the
world as well that freeze your sperm
i would highly recommend it you never
know what's going to happen
you never know god forbid who's going to
catch a cancer and
needs to treat a chemotherapy who's
going to get an autoimmune disorder
which affects your fertility and needs
to go on medications
freezing sperm is so easy and
comparatively to the female aspect
so inexpensive that i would recommend it
for all men and
especially doing this pandemic we've
realized that
many men are concerned about the
potential of fertility
um so they've been freezing sperm in our
office a lot of it
okay um what do you look for in a
healthy embryo
what does that mean so a healthy embryo
is an embryo
that is checked for its 46 chromosomes
making sure it has
exactly 46 and an x and a y chromosome
or two x chromosomes
it has to not be missing a chromosome it
has to not be having an extra chromosome
it has to not be missing a part of a
chromosome
that's what you call a healthy human
being so both you and i you're a 46
x x female and i'm a 46 x y
if we look different like a down
syndrome person
has an extra chromosome on their
chromosome number 21.
so we're looking to make sure the
chromosomes for 46
normal for a genetically normal embryo
if someone has a genetic problem in
their family like a disorder that many
people have had
or if we do genetic blood tests on a
male and a female
or even on a lesbian couple in the
future sperm donor or the opposite for a
gay couple and
a future egg donor if two people who are
going to reproduce with each other
do carry a genetic disorder this is now
not a chromosomal problem but a disorder
like cystic fibrosis sickle cell
disorder we can then do a special test
on their embryo
to make sure that the embryo that's
going to be transferred into the female
no longer has the diseased embryo going
in
and only has a carrier like the parent
or completely healthy without even being
a carrier state embryo
wow so you can get rid of genetic
disorders
some of them anyway basically as long as
they have been
linked to a chromosome we can go ahead
and
find them so sadly like autism has not
been linked
to a chromosome it's something that just
happens diabetes
hypertension has not but certain cancers
like braca one and brachipat ii breast
cancer
cancers have been linked and we are able
to
so if you have braca in your body and
you have a higher
way higher risk of breast cancer ovarian
cancer in the future
and you don't want to pass that on to
your child we are able to check to see
which embryo does not carry the bracha
gene
and then only transfers those back and a
lot of people do that
wow um okay so how do you look at how do
you look for healthy sperm what does
that look like
so when it comes to sperm we look for
sperm that has
um is motile in a moving well we look
for the sperm
counts that are high we also look for
the quality of the sperm which is
called morphology it's the normal forms
of sperm
and we look to see that the sperm has a
normal head
a normal neck and a normal tail that's
pretty much as much as we can do right
now we also have a technology in our
office called zymot zymot
the zymot chip is the newest technology
that came out
this year that we're using in our
practice where the sperm goes through a
special
chip that basically on the other end
once the sperm is passed through it
gets the sperm with the least amount of
oxidative damage meaning the healthiest
sperm out the other side
wow okay so same question for eggs how
do you identify a healthy egg
that's difficult you can't until you
make
the embryo you can't check if this egg
that was used to make that embryo was
healthy or not
okay and eggs we don't make millions of
eggs like we do sperm
and they're very fragile
okay so say you're a 30 year old you're
going in you're you're having eggs taken
out what's the average number of eggs
that you can have removed
i have 30 year olds that barely can make
two three eggs because their fertility
has already declined so much
i have patients that have made 45 eggs
but
the more eggs you make like past like 30
40 eggs
it's it then at that point you probably
have maybe like
polycystic ovary syndrome and sometimes
the quality of the eggs are worse i
think for someone who makes between 20
to 30 eggs i mean that's like an
excellent excellent number of eggs
and usually quality of people that are
that healthy with their fertility is
doing really well
okay so but there's no number you can
assign to someone
and people ask me all the time about
that specific number of that specific
age and it's really difficult to say
that
yeah that's fair that's fair enough um
so if you end up harvesting 20 eggs um
is there a certain number of embryos you
can end up making for
that person or is that really random too
it's beyond random i have had
44 year old women freeze two eggs and
got a beautiful baby out of it
i had people that were like 36 and froze
like 25
eggs and they came back to use them and
they could not get a good embryo out of
it
so that's why we give the the best
advice we give our patients is that the
more
you could make you have a higher chance
on the other end to have healthy
beautiful embryos
okay um what made you get into becoming
a fertility
specialist so i was doing
a residency program in obstetrics and
gynecology
when i got introduced to the world of
fertility and
for many reasons i thought it was a
perfect career path for myself
i have my undergraduate degree in
psychology
this is an area that on a daily basis
i'm working
with people's emotional well-being and
luckily for me and my personality i'm
able to be there
for patients i make sure that my team is
also very similar to myself that we are
able to hold people's hands through this
process and give the emotional support
that they need
i also love the science behind what i
did every single year
our field is growing rapidly and it's
also one of the newest
areas of medicine it's been around like
30 years and other areas of medicine
have been around hundreds of years
so it's just technologically advancing
very rapidly
i love the fact that there's science
involved and the research keeps changing
and things keep getting better and
better
um there's a lot of things and i i think
it's like i have the biggest gift in the
world because in my occupation
i change people's lives um i may be able
to help gay and lesbian patients
patients that have had major problems in
their health have
families that they never would have had
in the past and it's just beyond
rewarding
to be able to do that for patients so
i'm very fortunate i
and i also was beyond fortunate to have
gotten accepted into one of the
country's number one fellowship programs
which trained me so well
and now to be a partner in one of the
nation's number one fertility centers as
well
that's awesome um i had one question pop
up from instagram and it was a lesbian
couple
and they said how do how do you decide
which egg to use does that really
problem
it's the my best options are with my
lesbian couples because we have two sets
of eggs two sets of uterus
we have a lot of options for us um
there's many ways so sometimes we have a
lesbian couple coming in and they
say well i'm older and i'm going to go
first so we're going to do
artificial insemination with donors
sperm and hopefully it works
sometimes we do what's called reciprocal
ivf where we get the eggs out of the
body
make it with the sperm and then put the
embryo back in the other partner
so everyone's involved so the egg comes
from one partner
but then the other partner is the
gestational carrier um
and surrogate for the embryo there's a
lot of different options on how lesbian
partners do it there are some partners
in a lesbian relationship who just have
a zero desire to be pregnant and then
there's others
that both of them want to carry a baby
we've had every single scenario is
available
um for that and also it's a big part of
our practice by the way
um lgbt community is a big part of
scrc's practice here
yeah that doesn't surprise me that makes
sense um what about do you also end up
hooking up um
like gay partners with surrogate mothers
yeah absolutely so we have an entire
division at southern california
reproductive center here
where we have coordinators nurses
medical assistants who all they do is
help find you your egg donors
help find you your surrogates coordinate
the entire process
of making embryos then transferring them
to different
surrogates and doing that entire process
for our patients
we even have something that i it's a
very rare thing there's only a few
i think i've heard of in the country but
we have what's called a third party
concierge
so if you hire this person um there is a
nominal fee which
it's i think is the best money ever
spent she will actually help you
find your egg donor help you find your
surrogate she has meetings with you
about the characteristics and everything
that you
like to have and want to have um
so you can kind of have that entire
process available to you
and she does the work and finds you
those people yeah it's amazing
okay uh changing topics slightly again
not really but um
does the iud or the birth control pill
do people who have been on that have a
harder time making eggs or getting
pregnant
that you've seen so we always ask
patients if they use an iud
if it was uncomplicated and they didn't
have a problem or an infection or
anything
very unlikely that it would have
affected the lining of the uterus in any
way negatively
the birth control pill if you're on
birth control for a
really really long time sometimes it
really suppresses the ovary meaning that
it just like reduces
the eggs that are awake and it takes a
little while for the ovary to come back
to life
so what's the either of the hard time
look like i think it
uh i mean i've had patients that were on
birth control like 15 years
20 years since their teenage years and
they just got used to being on it
i think it's a good idea for those
patients to assess their fertility
um and be off of the birth control for
anywhere between a month to
three months before trying to start
fertility but then again if you're like
40 years old i don't know if you need to
be waiting three months to start
yeah okay okay fair enough um
let me see do i have any other questions
for you you just burned through those
i think that's i think that's basically
it um
if people are looking for you online
where can they find you
i think the easiest way to find me is my
instagram and the different social media
channels which are dr shahid dadir
it's dr shaheen gadir it's a verified
page
and probably the easiest way i also have
a podcast that launched called the
fertile life
where we talk about all things fertility
related and lifestyle related which has
been launched about a month and a half
ago and doing incredibly well
and very fun so just like i love talking
here we talk a lot about this stuff and
a lot of things
have to do with uh people's life as well
not
just the fertility aspect of it but
other things that affect the fertility
aspect of it
and you can always call the clinic and
make a consultation and we do consults
for patients around the world and people
are flying in these days even with
everything going on
and getting pregnant and leaving
successfully so we're really proud of
that
that's awesome okay so last question i i
do have a few more it turns out
um so these other aspects that can
affect your fertility
um how does say diet or stress
like what are these other factors people
might want to take into consideration
i just like anything in your life i
think trying to be as healthy as
possible promotes
good outcomes and being very unhealthy
promotes bad outcomes so
i think if you're in your reproductive
years and you care about your fertility
and you care about your health
you should try to be as healthy as
possible you know normal amounts of
well-balanced diet and exercise i think
are important for any reproductive age
woman and man
um i think stress stress is awful and it
affects
everything in your body including your
fertility and trying to learn how to
manage that
in a very complicated world right now is
challenging
but you need to do the best that you can
okay well dr gadir thank you very much
for coming on and i will link
your social media and your podcast below
thank you thank you so much that was
fascinating thank you
i love that interview you asked
excellent questions by the way
thank you thank you very much thank you
for having me on today
[Music]
you